why is it right after i do a whole bunch
of rapid fire videos and i think to
myself i need to slow down but something
happens that i'm like crap now i gotta
talk about that
even though i haven't gotten around to
addressing this franchise in animation
junk yet i am an absolutely massive fan
of ghost in the shell so that means i
need to address the news that scarlet
johansen has been confirmed as playing
the lead in the live-action adaptation
of that same property now i need to
start by sort of setting aside the fact
that i kind of wish the movie wasn't
happening at all i have a very inherent
negative reaction to whenever an
animated property gets remade as a
live-action film i've got pretty
deep-seated reasons for that but
honestly that's a discussion for another
time so we'll stick a pin on that we'll
come back to that later so if i just
sort of embrace the fact that this movie
is happening whether i wanted to or not
scarlett johansson honestly not a bad
pick now i don't think the official
announcement actually name checked that
she was going to be playing major motoko
kusanagi that's obviously the character
she's gonna be playing i suspect the
reason they haven't dropped the name yet
is that name may get changed because
it's such an inherently japanese name
and scarlett johansson just
isn't but as far as this casting goes
yeah honestly i think this is about as
good as we're gonna get if this movie
does in fact have to happen my concerns
aren't so much with her it's actually
what story are they gonna tell cause
what i'm really worried about is that
they're going to actually basically just
remake the original story from the manga
which was the basis for that 1995 first
film that kicked everything off and that
would be a huge mistake to explain why i
do have to delve into the ending a
little bit so consider this a spoiler
warning it may end up being completely
moot if they don't base it off that
story but warning all the same if they
do that story which centers around the
villain called the puppet master then
really they don't get to use the major
again in future stories she doesn't die
at the end of that story but she merges
with this artificial intelligence and
abandons her physical body so while
she's still out there she is not the
central character for future stories and
we don't see her in that same physical
form now we have to assume that from a
studio perspective this is intended to
kick off a franchise i mean it's going
to be expensive and if they're going to
sink this much money into it they're
going to want to get more than one film
out of the property which means they're
not going to allow scarlett johansson to
effectively only be used once and then
drop the character so what that means is
if they use the story of the puppet
master and what happens at the end of
that they're gonna have to change the
ending so that they can keep scarlett
johansson around but if they do that
they fundamentally betray and miss the
point of what that story is because what
happens at the end is really vital to
paying off everything that builds up up
to that point now what could work and
what i'm kind of hoping they're doing is
that they save that for maybe a third
entry in a trilogy and what they start
us off with is basically what the tv
series standalone complex did which was
to take those characters those themes
that world but tell original stories
that still were honoring all of those
things i think if they do that or if
they borrow elements from standalone
complex or innocence or other stories
that aren't the puppet master and craft
a new story around that then that could
work and you can build up the sort of
existential crisis and the questioning
of herself and what is life what is
intelligence what is being human the
kind of questions that the major
grapples with that cause her to make the
decisions that she makes by the end of
the puppet master story which as i said
would actually be a hell of a capper for
a third story in a trilogy right now we
don't know if that's happening it is
still kind of being referred to as a
remake of ghost in the shell right now
so that's a slight red flag for me but
it's early enough in the process that
maybe just maybe that won't be the case
we gotta wait for a bit more we gotta
wait for director or other cast members
but honestly right now the big hinge for
me is gonna be the story so those are my
thoughts funnily enough not really so
much about the casting i use that as a
leaping off point to
rant about other things anyways i felt
the need to talk about this all the same
are you familiar with ghosts in the show
what is your favorite ghost in the show
story or property is it the manga is it
the films is it the tv series is it the
new one ghost in the show rise which
actually i haven't caught up on yet but
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned
you